What on
earth
oh we need a
plan Tony can we liven it up Friday drop
a beat
yes nice Shield cap you too
cap you dance but of
course Dan for
smash
who are you I'm the collector behold my
collection when you get to be as big a
deal as I am it's all about rare one of
a kind but it's still not enough that's
why I've decided to collect Avengers
take
them anyone have any ideas we need
someone with special skills no not that
guy he's the best at what he does and
what he does isn't very
[Music]
nice guess I'm not going to get to eat
my
lunch Mom's Diner that's just adorable
it's probably a death trap oh
boy activate scan and sword functions
two animals excuse
me we're going to build our way
out it's time to collect a little
payback
now you are going to be impressed by
this th buddy uh-oh I overdressed ah
better change no no R
it
nice